okay so after last week's big DC
announcement I went to bed thinking that
things would work themselves out and it
was gonna be fine over the weekend we
had a number of things happening and I
actually used the powers of cognitive
reasoning to work out why Henry Cavill
had to be staying as Superman in the DCU
now listening so so here's what I
thought James Gunn yeah he's married to
Jennifer Holland Holland plays hardcore
in Suicide Squad Peacemaker and also
Black Adam Black Adam ends with a tease
towards Superman and therefore the only
way that Henry Cavill was out is if Gunn
had decided to ruin his marriage and
make it so that all the movies with his
wife in it didn't matter anymore I
thought there's no way that's happening
and then Josh from denim nerds put out a
tweet saying that James Gunn doesn't
like Henry Cavill which gun actually
debunked dealt out one of the most
brutal ratios of all time complete body
bag destroyed him and I thought yeah
Henry Cavill he's safe however it turns
out that was a [ __ ] lie and Henry
Cavill has been kicked to the curb after
only just announcing that he was back
it's a [ __ ] show and Henry was like
Black Adam we need to talk we're both at
the DCU
for sake guessing James guns filing
those divorce papers right now and as
always if he gonna be DC fan you're
gonna have a bad time throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
Henry cavill's Post James Gunn's reply
and also talking about the implications
of this I really think that the
snyderverse is definitely over at this
point as we have Cavill out Mamoa is
probably going to be playing Lobo and
judging by James Gunn's comments Affleck
is possibly going to be brought into
direct something anyway we're going to
be getting into it all and please hit
the Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy the
video and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day with that
out of the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
video
okay so last night Henry Cavill posted
this I have just had a meeting with
James Gunn and Peter Safran and it's sad
news everyone I will after all not be
returning as Superman after being told
by the studio to announce my return back
in October prior to their higher this
news isn't the easiest but that's life
the changing of the god is something
that happens I respect that James and
Peter have a universe to build I wish
them and all involved with the new
universe the best of luck and happiest
of Fortunes for those who've been by my
side through the airs we can mourn for a
bit but then we must remember Superman
is still around starting to cry up a bit
everything he stands for still exists
the examples he sets for us are still
there my turn to where the cape has
passed but what Superman stands for
never will it's been a fun ride with you
all onwards and upwards so kind of
crushing and thanks for coming in to do
that Henry it's kind of crushing
especially due to the fact that Cavill
just quit the witch in order to likely
give his full attention to his return as
Superman the guy's been messed about so
much over the last decade and added
donning the cape for 2013's Man of Steel
he has been brushed to the side Superman
should be a flagship character but he
was swept under the rug and he became
shrouding his soups for several years
where we didn't know whether he was in
or out however hope hope came back with
Black Adam and it seemed like cavil was
finally coming back there were Rumblings
of a Man of Steel 2 script being worked
on and it was confirmed that he filmed
the Cameo for the flash however at The
Hollywood Reporter posted last week that
this Cameo had been removed and that he
was completely out the universe Gunn did
a big post saying some of it was true
and some of it wasn't unfortunately we
now know what was happening now Josh got
a lot of [ __ ] over the weekend for
saying that he heard Gunn doesn't like
Cavill but I I don't know how else you
chop it up in all honesty perhaps I
treated you too harshly and though I
don't want to steer the pot unless this
is a full 100 reboot then there's not
really any way that you can say
otherwise if some of the actors from the
old God are kept in Cavill isn't then
yeah maybe he doesn't like him but I do
want to try and stay away from the
gossip as much as possible however the
Optics on this they're not that good now
I do also think it's important to know
that the rock fought with execs to bring
Henry Cavill back for this to just be
completely overlooked now has probably
rubbed The Rock The Rock away and Gunn
probably feels like he's stuck between
the rock in a hard place I highly doubt
that Black Adam is going to be back
anytime soon either because of the box
office performance and the fact that the
post-credits scene now means absolutely
nothing at all this will probably annoy
a lot of people as well that bore
tickets to Black Adam just to see
caval's return and I think that it's a
big misfire by gun Now Guns reply to
this reads Peter and I have a DC slate
ready to go which we couldn't be more
over the moon about we'll be able to
share some exciting information about
our first projects at the beginning of
the new year among those on the Slate is
Superman in the initial stages our story
will be focusing on an earlier part of
Superman's life so the character will
not be played by Henry Cavill we just
had a great meeting with Henry and we're
big fans and we're talking about a
number of exciting possibilities to work
together in the future which probably
won't happen it's like you know whenever
you ask someone to do something and they
go well I'll try it often means they're
not going to do it mate that's just in
general if someone if you ever asked
someone and they go I'll try they're not
gonna do it and I kind of get that
feeling reading these I don't think
Henry's gonna be back and I think they
were just being polite and be like yeah
we've got got loads of exciting
opportunities for you in the future
we'll try get you involved now at this
point I also don't think that we need
another early life Superman movie though
gonna say that it won't be an origin
story I really just don't want to see
the character fighting their feet again
and meeting Lois and all this stuff like
that soups is at the point where he
should now be fighting massive massive
space threats and characters like
Brainiac and Mongol Black Adam as well
would have been a big opponent for him
but instead we're going back to his
roots for another one of them we have
the technology now where big things can
be pulled off and I think it's a massive
misfire to not only fire caval from the
gun but to also go back to that point in
Superman's life it's something that's
been done since the 70s in movies TV
shows and comics and personally I feel
that if you want to make Superman
gripping for new audiences that you need
to move on from this and actually give
us something we haven't seen thousands
of times before now we know that gun is
gonna be writing the movie so at the
very least this script will probably be
good he is a great writer and director
but I just wish he didn't have to throw
the baby out with a bath water because I
don't think Henry Cavill deserves it I
actually hope this clears the slope for
Henry and that the girls only become
Bond or something because I think in the
long run d PC is probably going to be a
show for a long time and it might be
better to avoid what's coming because it
really could go either way there's all
this talk of a 10-year plan but if it
doesn't immediately hit the ground
running then I think Warner Brothers
will do what Warner Brothers always do
they'll Panic force people to come in
and take control of things and then that
10-year plan will end up looking like a
two-year one that has multiple changes
in it now interestingly we know from
Rumblings over at Marvel that the
Thunderbolts movie is gonna have an evil
Superman and I really hope that Marvel
will give Henry a call if he hasn't been
cast yet I can actually see a lot of
characters jumping ship to Marvel
because at the moment DC just seems like
a mess and let's be honest Marvel could
do with some a-listers as part of their
new phase anyway gonna also talked about
how they spoke with Ben Affleck
yesterday and that he wants to direct
they just need to find the right project
for him now if I was Affleck again I I
probably would wait for them to
establish the universe first because
getting pulled into all this stuff again
like guy got messed around so much with
Batman and yeah if I was him I'd be like
uh you know I might focus on something
that's actually gonna happen now I also
think that announcements like this with
us likely getting a clean slate means
that the rest of the dceu is [ __ ]
Aquaman 2 The Flash and Shazam they just
seem like things that are going to be
completely pointless to see now because
they're being sold as shared Universe
movies for a shared universe that isn't
gonna be around I obviously will cover
them for the channel but in situations
like this I often try and put myself in
a space where I think if I'd bother
going to see something if it wasn't my
job I really don't think I'd bother with
Aquaman and Shazam and I'll probably
only go and see the flash for Keaton so
it's it's weird for them to announce
this massive reboot when all those films
are coming out now in our last video I
talked about how I think they should
have ended this movie Universe with a
movie and got everyone back for one
final swan song before it was all put to
rest now I actually think this might
even be the beginning of the end for
comic book movies and they could slowly
start to Fade Into Obscurity because of
stuff like this DC fans have invested 10
years of their lives into the DCU at
this point and throughout it we've been
told to be patient and that things will
pay off that clearly hasn't been the
case and I don't know if have it in me
for another 10-year plan that that's
going to end when I turn 45 Marvel's
also been underperforming too and with
phase 4 definitely being a step down it
seems like this might be the beginning
of the end for the genre sure that they
will they will still be comic book
movies that come out but I don't think
they're gonna be the massive juggernauts
that we once had and you can see why too
because moves like this always feel like
a girl punch to fans now the studio
doesn't seem interested in what fans
want then the fans will end up not being
interested in what they want either so I
think this is a bad move especially with
how much Goodwill there was to DC after
he was brought back by Black Adam now
earlier in the week there were rumors
that Matt Reeves as Batman was going to
be brought into the ECU as the main one
this was debunked by gun and Matt Reeves
and at least that and Joker will
probably remain off in their own
separate universes now we also got word
back from Paddy Jenkins as well over
what happened with Wonder Woman 3. she
said sigh I'm not a
always good with a post starts with that
sigh I'm not one to talk about private
career matters but I will not allow
inaccuracies to continue here are the
facts I originally left Rogue Squadron
after a long productive development
process when it became clear it couldn't
happen soon enough and I did not want to
delay Wonder Woman 3 any further when I
did lucasfilm asked me to consider
coming back to Rogue Squadron after
Wonder Woman 3 which I was honored to do
so so I agreed they made a new deal with
me in fact I am still on it and that
project has been an active development
ever since I don't know if it will
happen or not we never do until the
development process is complete but look
forward to its potential ahead so at
least we're getting Rogue Squadron out
of this at least that now when this
started being backlash about Wonder
Woman 3 not happening the attractive
click sound a bit like Michael Jackson
the attractive clickbait false story
that it was me that killed it or walked
away started to spread this is simply
not true and never walked away I was
open to considering anything asked of me
it was my understanding there was
nothing I could do to move anything
forward at this time DC is obviously
better than changes they are having to
make so understand these decisions are
difficult right now I do not want what
has been a beautiful Journey with Wonder
Woman to land on a negative note I have
loved and been honored to be the person
who got to make these last two wonder
woman films she's an incredible
character living in and around her
values makes me a better person every
day I wish her and her Legacy an amazing
feature ahead with or without me walking
side by side with Linda Carter an
absolute Legend and Beacon of goodness
and light has been a thrill I've learned
so much from her and I will cherish her
as a friend and Mentor always my crew
has been like one of them my crew has
been like family and thought every day
to give the world the best films they
could and gal Gal Gadot where do I begin
gal is the greatest gift I've ever seen
believed in this whole journey a
cherished friend inspiration and sister
there are no words I can use to convey
how magical she is she is the walking
embodiment of Wonder Woman in real life
and a better person than the world can
imagine never once in a million moments
I've spent with her did I see anything
less she is a gift of this world and
even more so to me lastly however you
wrap it up lastly but most importantly
thank you to you the incredible Wonder
Woman fans and for all your love and
support Wonder Woman fans are often not
the most visible in media and online but
I want you to know that we've always
seen and celebrated you and your
importance you are the first and
foremost in our mind every day we made
the last two films you are the best and
most loving people and I look forward to
your always come on thank you for all
for this wonderful Journey cute with one
of the spirit
I hope a beacon of love and truth and
Justice is always there to lead the way
for you as she's done from a great
speech there yeah so no mention there of
um Gal Gadot not get moving forward and
as you know James Gunn has announced as
either or gal then she might still be in
the role however as I've been saying in
this video I think that if Henry is out
then that means everything has to go
everything I don't want to see no Side
characters from Suicide Squad kept
Cannon if my man Henry is out burn them
all to the [ __ ] ground I think their
fans are gonna be pretty mad because
it's not like Cavill was disliked every
time you do something like this as well
you of course run the risk that things
won't work out and people will be
annoyed to get rid of someone to put
your new vision forward that isn't as
good it's a big risk Anthony it puts DC
off on the wrong foot going forward
however at this point I think gun may
think the old Universe comes with too
much baggage and they just want to get
rid but will it work well that's what
I'm putting over to you Patty's Pet
Patty tell them we're putting it over to
you do you think it's gonna work eating
him Rogue squadron's gonna be good let
me keep an eye out for Rogue Squadron
yeah so yeah comment below and let us
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our Brighton of Spider-Man
across the spider-verse which will be
linked on the screen right now great
trailer lots of things going on you're
gonna love the video you take care of
yourself I'm out peace